Radio: Police are still on the lookout for what sources are calling: The Uberkiller.
The serial murderer uses the popular rideshare service
to isolate victims.
Authorities are encouraging extreme caution when using the ride-share application.
You call for an Ubar?
Yep. Can you help me with my bag?
You need help with that little thing?
So whatcha got in that little bag of yours anyways?
Oh... not much... just some clothes.
I was hoping to have room for some souvenirs on the way back.
What?
Nothing. Nothing...
You can actually go straight here.
Don't worry hun. I know a shortcut.
I... I need to get out.
Relax sweetheart.
Really?
Just pull over!
As you wish..
*1930s Jazz Music*
*screaming*
*gagging*
Radio: Authorities are encouraging extreme caution for drivers using the service in the area.
Especially in the late hours of the night.
They also recommend working with a buddy.
Remember...
The Uberkiller...
Could be anyone.
Thanks for watching Uberhorror.
We were wondering. When you ride in these things, do you usually sit in the front or the back?
Let us know in the comments.
If you like this video, be sure to like this video and subscribe for new horrors every month.
And if you like the voice on the radio, check out Lets Read's channel.
He does horror narrations, lists and creepypasta.
If you want more horror films, check out this playlist and we'll see you in the next video.
Assuming we survive...